[Music]
jerry i really like to know your
intentions what ed honey consider the
weirdness of what you're doing
ooh boy i miss did you just arrive here
from our parallel universe
organ put down your commitment to
narcissism and go talk with an old
person i I have a school somewhere I
have to get the wisdom of an old person
roxeanne everybody I I don't know any
old people hey hey kid you drive so sir
Oh me ash what did you do for a living
hey don't tell me your friend I don't
have any friends ask anyone I don't have
any friends real friend no now you're
just mocking me could at least learn how
to take a punch if you'll no doubt have
to take many you're not touching my
son's privates are you she's it was a
touching me
how many people did you fill 93 you're
very strange kid there's a rumor going
around that you turn into a jock I
assume you'll turn back into a pumpkin
at midnight though vagina I know he's
this man with wings on his feet I may be
jealous
why not going out technically is she
your friend yeah did you let her down
yeah we got to make amends with a girl
you feel me what once you're scared of
us and I'd be crazy
I know we're going to visit a friend
yeah what do you have to run okay we'll
go to New York and I'll take the drive
up we don't go see Jersey Boys together
let's see you play with you or something
you should be scared of the world I kind
of suspect the world speaks fair to you
I swear to God I won't write about that
you're an assassin in my paper even
though it would make a better paper
let's grab some pancakes
[Music]
agent Hollywood Activia that's fine
again Madame la bubi totally unique
within range of holiness what's answer
to the soda my CIA again - so - the cop